she-she and america police have
described this as a near-miss on a
country lane on Friday lunchtime this
driver appears confused those filming it
realize the plates of foreign and later
report it to police a number plate check
confirmed that it's an American
diplomats car from nearby RAF Croton it
was all captured on Jack's Dunn's dash
cam she just come around the corner and
then she come on my side of the road and
it was just so quick even though we were
both going fairly slow it just happened
so quick and it you know it was quite
scary it was just a few miles from where
Harry Dunne was killed in a collision
with American answer coulis she just
left the u.s. spy base and admitted she
was on the wrong side of the road
she claimed diplomatic immunity and left
the country now police have revealed
that there has been a third incident
where one of their own vehicles were
struck in Northampton in October by a
driver whose car was from RAF Croton now
there were no injuries and no immunity
has been claimed but the investigation
is ongoing in a statement
Northampton Chief Constable Nick
Adderley said I want to be absolutely
clear on the fact that these incidents
just cannot keep happening we know all
too well in the case of young Harry just
how devastating they can be therefore
the police fire and crime Commissioner
and I have today requested an urgent
meeting with the base commander Atari of
Croton to discuss safety on the roads
around the base and they expect this
meeting to take place next week
supporters of the campaign for justice
for Harry have warned of escalating
protests if the US doesn't listen the
u.s. embassy says they won't comment on
the recent cases just not like it's a
singletrack road it is as big as their
two cars past lobbies you can see
plenty of room Harry's dad Tim was
shocked to see the video this is not
just a one-off thing for Harry is it
it's obviously getting more and more
brought to the attention so we need to
somehow highlight this and things need
to change there are new signs near the
base urging drivers to keep left
but for Harry's family it's not enough
the Foreign Office has confirmed they're
still discussing safety and immunity
arrangements with the u.s. they called
the new reports disturbing and said the
government would do all they could to
prevent a repeat of Harry's devastating
case Lisa Dale Sky News Northampton Show